avete presente l'estate scorsa che
faceva un caldo bestia acquista anche tu
favi ventilatore
il fai ventilatore e dotato dell'ultima
tecnologia all'avanguardia per la
climatizzazione dell'area non sporca non
fa troppo rumore e funzione a pila di tu
sai dove vanno inserite quest'estate è
peggio
ho provato a sdraiarmi per terra marte o
il parquet e fa ancora più caldo ho
provato anche ad attaccarmi al
condizionatore solo che l'ultima volta
che l'ho fatto ho visto due ragni dentro
ho anche provato a schiavizzare degli
amici non ha funzionato come speravo
ho provato anche a rovesciarmi un
miliardo di paula retti in faccia e così
la situazione è leggermente migliorata
devo dire solo che la situazione era
leggermente scomoda se anche tu sei
stanco di tutto questo caldo fai come me
l'anno scorso invia un sms che ho
scritto cristo che caldo altre 33 66 69
c'è v.lo a casa oggi stesso attenzionati
fa di ventilatore potrebbe avere ferilli
svelati quali politica aveva frutto
appunto non somministrare condividete
inferiore a quanto ci viene quasi la
prima volta che faccio un mio video in
cucina per l'occasione ho dovuto pulire
per terra ho trovato scott e bottiglie
d'acqua quote calzini e da tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono
vari j
ed oggi siamo in un nuovo blog prima di
cominciare vorrei far vedere la fanar
della settimana che questa settimana è
stata vinta da alessandro che ha fatto
sta disegno nerissimo è veramente
veramente figo piu figo del pan di
stelle che sta dietro e direi di partire
con il video di oggi che non tratta
soltanto di scottex e calzini del cazzo
di avevo detto che al mio ritorno da los
angeles avrei fatto l'unboxing di un
sacco di roba che ho comprato durante il
viaggio
la prima volta che andai a los angeles
me lo ricordo ancora comprai un sacco di
roba utilissima tra l'altro tipo la
cacca di aral e da quando questa la mia
vita è cambiata in meglio comunque sia
ragazzo raccolto tutte le cose che ho
comprato nell'ultimo viaggio sono tutte
quante raccolte qua dentro in questo
zaino
poi sembra tipo uno di quei video cosa
c'è nel mio zaino shell ebola sono già
riempito il bicchiere d'acqua perché
probabilmente andrò ad assaggiare delle
cagate allora ragazzi la prima roba che
offre voi non avete idea di che cosa
stava succedendo in questo istante cosa
ho salvato stava cascando tutto a parte
il fatto che stavo per morire andiamo
avanti che è meglio la prima cosa che ho
preso ragazzi è stata questa filemaker
freddy's che poi tra l'altro è un veloce
ha fatto vedere questo rosse sarò ma io
vi giuro non mi ricordo di che cosa
ma che cazzo io ho comprato questa cosa
non mi ricordavo di aver già yoda dopo
toyota cuscino ragazzi abbiamo una
maglietta presa si prestava la maglietta
playstation quando vado alle feste
galanti o quando tentò di rimorchiare le
[ __ ] ne darò una dimostrazione proprio
adesso
adesso sì che rimorchio come un puledro
a questa roba questa roba qua e la vita
la prima roba che vi faccio vedere tra
queste sono loro gli occhiali di harry
potter pagati la bellezza di non so se
si vede 8 dollari e 95 non sono anche
proprio speso 8 dollari perticato gli
occhiali profumi
ci vuole un dettaglio in più fermi
nativo
[Musica]
vi sarete forse chiedendo come cazzo hai
fatto favia farla così realistica della
serie che proprio rosso di poe cicatrice
come non c'ho pennarelli in casa ho
provato a farlo con la penna solo che la
pena non scrive un cazzo ho passato
l'ultima mezz'ora a farmi così e vi si è
creato proprio un solco sulla mia fronte
quindi questa pagina cicatrice bera
andiamo avanti ragazzi con questi che
sono dovrebbero essere dei magneti di
tetris da attaccare al frigo e che è na
figata il problema è che il mio frigo
non ci parte che era un cazzo perché non
ci si attaccano i magneti va a
francolino ho comprati far niente per
altri 8 dollari e 95 buttati nel cesso
adesso passiamo alla parte [ __ ]
innanzitutto ragazzi queste caramelle
alla cannella esplosive io col piccante
ci faccio a cazzotti a nome excluding
significa che esplode nonché piccante
ora che brutta la scatolina spaccio ed
io vi sembra che io mi sia per mangiare
nitroglicerina borja minotta ci provo
continua stop vent'anni la poca perché
se mia madre non guardasse i miei vi do
sarebbe tutto più semplice il
presentimento che stasera mia madre mi
urlerà in faccia al telefono per quello
che ho appena fatto la regola numero uno
per tutti quanti gli youtubers non dite
a vostra madre qual è il vostro canale
youtube ci sono due altre cose di harry
potter che ho preso che devo
assolutamente provare sono numero uno le
lumache e commosse di harry potter e il
numero due caramelle tutti i gusti p1
sono riuscito veramente a trovarle le
caramelle tutti i gusti più non lo
comprate subito in me come l'ho visto e
che non ne ho comprata una scatola sola
non comprate 4 partiamo ragazzi con le
lumache gommose non ho idea di che cosa
che ci possa trovare dentro però sarà
fighissimo che bella che è fantastico
devo proprio ingerirli questa roba devo
proprio farlo
[Musica]
possiamo utilizzare questo come
sacchetto del vomito grazie siamo
arrivati al momento decisivo ragazzi le
caramelle tutti i gusti più uno a cento
scritto che cosa sono state terminati
con questa qua in basso c'è scritto che
e vomito almeno so quale non prende ed è
effettivamente la prima che vedo nella
scatola bellissimi fusco vomito è caduta
a [ __ ] che merda trova favore mente
schifo lo pensavo così tanto e si vede
facciamo così schifo si devono tipo
togliermi sapore dalla bocca
dopo la rete è va bene su una pena
grazie con la penna lo ha proprio la
pendeva ricordi da ricordi ma non si
toglie la cravatta piace ha funzionato
contro fighissimi e tutti ci sono cocco
non so leggere koch l'ananas chivu e
mambo moretti troppi comuni gusti per
tipi tosti sentito tosto giorgio io
tanti ma che tipo tosto che al qaida
tipo tosto
dopo le carte ma cosa fai mile chi può
dare ma basta ma vai via vada vada può
la rete è per tutti ragazzi tosti in
cerca di avventura 6 tosto giorgio
adorna cosa fa quello è così uscito
perché una cosa fa andiamo avanti
ragazzi con le cose che ho preso ce ne
sono altrettante di pronti questo
ragazzi l'ho preso quando sono andato in
sala giochi che ho provato a vincere
qualcosa no vinto un cazzo ovviamente
sarebbe una supposta una mega supposta
di gomma l'altra cosa che ho preso e
questo alieno giallo cielo perché ho
provato per chi ha visto il blog ho
provato a fare canestro per vincere
lascia di minecraft che c'era lascia di
minecraft bellissima per vincerla
bisognava fare tipo 2 canestri su tre io
ne ho fatto uno su tre è mandato questa
roba per consolazione che è tristissimo
prove
domenica i ragazzi abbiamo questo guscio
che sarebbe quello che veramente metti
sotto il culo degli altri per falli
scoreggiare e avrete la vostra laurea in
filosofia in men che non si dica
dopodiché i ragazzi mi ero dimenticato
sta roba aumento anche questo che lo
conosco perché tipo l'avevo visto in una
puntata del laboratorio di dexter tv 200
anni fa a se tu metti un dito da una
parte un dito dall'altra gli inserisci
se poi provi a tirare non funziona in
teoria non dovrebbero uscire le ditte e
bisogna farlo con un amico prendete un
amico è in it e mette il dito dall'altra
parte lui lo mette non vi staccate più
utile per chi soffre di firenze come
ultimo acquisto di questo incredibile
viaggio che ho fatto a los angeles c'è
la tavola ouija con tanto di fazzoletto
pieno di caramelle appiccicose attaccate
dietro qualsiasi demone andrò a evocare
sicuramente sarà coperto di caramelle
appiccicosa al vomito ho speso dei soldi
per comprare questa roba che voi mi
direte ma quanto sei scemo favi no no so
proprio [ __ ] non credo
effettivamente che sta roba serve
evocare i demoni lo possiamo provarci
anche se è una cagata come al solito e
della stessa frase che dicono i
protagonisti dei film horror prima di
venire a triturati a sangue ma
sorvoliamo come i ragazzi questi sono
stati i miei acquisti a los angeles non
chiedetemi come ho fatto a portarli a
casa perché c'era tutto sto popò di roba
però ho capito che sia piaciuto ragazzi
se arriviamo a solo se arriviamo a
100.000 life parola challenge delle
caramelle tutti i gusti più uno quindi
se volete vedere questo cia con qualcuno
sicuramente perché da solo è troppo
forever a londra chiaro di incastrare
qualche mio amico questa roba
e poi lo costringerò a fare la challenge
tre ragazzi sarà capito vi sia piaciuto
spero che questi acquisti siano di
vostro gradimento come solito lasciato
il momento è un mi piace condividete
questo video con la vostra nonna per
farle vedere quanto sono buone queste
quanto serva questa se non sia vestiti
16 vediamo al prossimo video della
ragazza
[Musica]
lasciati parenti spetta giuro
solennemente di non avere buone
intenzioni vai così così e basta ma lui
mi sa che ti ho anche il possibile ma
che schifo fatti che si sono mangiati
però che la resti a me